jupiter is a pretty little town on the
east coast of florida it's about 90
miles north of miami it's not a huge
place it's a safe and orderly place a
ton of nice people live there not all of
them by the way are rich which is
unusual for a coastal town it's a normal
place in other words it's the country
you remember you wouldn't mind living
there for sure
but over the weekend jupiter florida
looked less like the america of 1980 and
more like the america that joe biden is
busy creating right now which is to say
chaotic crazy out of control
families sitting on the beach in jupiter
this sunday watched slack jawed as a
boat carrying dozens of unemployed
illegal immigrant haitians suddenly
pulled up on shore the people inside the
boat hopped out ran through the waves
and scattered
not would you expect on a sunday on the
beach but not everybody in jupiter was
surprised to see this happen another
boat full of haitians had landed there
just this summer so it's becoming a
regular occurrence in jupiter florida
in the end this sunday federal
authorities caught a number of the
migrants according to customs and border
protection the haitians will be
processed for removal proceedings feel
better you shouldn't that doesn't mean
they're being sent home
in fact most of them will not be sent
home most will stay here forever
they didn't come here legally they came
here illegally take a look at this chart
it shows data compiled by syracuse
university these are the results of
immigration hearings so far under joe
biden you'll notice that more than 70
percent of illegal aliens have been
allowed to stay in your country
after their so-called deportation
proceedings there's no deportation
involved
immigration officers hate this they're
not allowed to do their jobs but they're
not in control joe biden is in control
and joe biden is trying to change this
country as fast as he possibly can
you may not know this most americans
have no idea it's happening but the rest
of the world is watching closely so if
you live in an impoverished country and
you'd like a better job and free schools
and free health care courtesy of
american taxpayers come on in and they
are
the sheriff's office the best way i can
describe the border right now is chaos
absolute chaos the arizona national
guard this has been the largest surge of
immigrants that i have seen in my career
since october of this year customs and
border protection reported close to 22
thousand encounters in the yuma sector
that's a two thousand six hundred
percent increase from this time last
year dennis cook's backyard overlooks
the unfinished border wall he sees the
crossings every day and knows just how
overwhelmed border patrol is there's
times when life called border patrol and
border patrols we can't do anything
we're totally booked up we can't do
nothing with them since since i've been
on camera here i bet you we've had 20
people cross already
this is totally crazy and third world
you're not supposed to mention it
they've racialized everything
so you can't say anything most
republicans have been intimidated into
silence they don't want to be called
names
but the truth is nothing like this has
ever happened in the united states and
it's important for two reasons the first
is the rule of law remember that
so there are people right now still
being held in solitary confinement
because they trespassed in a building
that technically they own it's called
the capital of the united states
and they're still there
they're still in jail
but millions of foreign nationals just
walk in ignoring our laws completely and
that's totally cool because equity or
something
how can anybody respect the laws of the
united states when they are being
ignored by the people in charge of
enforcing them there's a massive cost to
that
and here's the second point to make you
cannot overstate the scale of
demographic change underway right now in
the united states it's a direct assault
on our democracy
democracy is the process by which the
population elects its representatives if
you change the population you dilute the
political power of the people who
already live there this is an assault on
democracy at what scale here's an
example customs and border protection
caught more than 170 000 foreign
nationals crossing into our country from
mexico
last month
how many people is that well that's the
equivalent of the entire population of
knoxville tennessee
in a single month that's a record but
it's happening every month
month after month
under joe biden and those are just the
people we're catching
so this and let's not lie about it this
is the democratic party's re-election
plan new york is already allowing
non-citizens to vote expect that trend
to spread because equity
has nothing to do with equity or race
it's about politics it's the whole point
of this now in the end a lot of these
people may turn out to have political
views the democratic party does not
expect whatsoever
particularly the latino immigrants will
have a lot more on that in a minute
but purely as an economic matter this is
a disaster
no wise person would do this
this country is getting poorer in part
because of inflation no one wants to
face that truth but it is true
is this really the time to import
millions of low-skilled laborers
probably not
what are all these people going to be
doing for work in 10 years
that's a real question the current labor
shortage has accelerated the automation
of low-skilled jobs it's really simple
ask anybody with a business employers
can't find workers how are they
responding well they're buying more
robots
food delivery service grubhub for
example has rolled out autonomous
delivery on college campuses across the
country that's happening everywhere
so there's going to be a lot less low
skilled work available very soon how's
that going to end for us we've got
millions of new arrivals with no jobs
opening the border may be the single
most destructive thing that any
administration has ever done to this
country hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else